ladies and gentlemen my name is Greg
Alba and I'm John Humphrey we are the
real rejects we started this channel
some time ago like six years ago now
five no I think it's six to twelve years
twelve we've had this channel and for
the longest time there has been one
company I have wanted to work for as of
a few weeks ago we finally got that
email we've been waiting for
I was not professional at all I just
said hell hells yeah I've been waiting
for someone
email us we're working with Luke right
now people look specifically loot gaming
this has been the one company why
because I think when you're youtuber
who's made it your Parker would Lou
crazy this is just for us I think you
guys should totally buy one we are Luke
Raycom slash 8.8 the real rejects that's
our area code might make it easier for
you to narrow down where we live your
local listings
Comstock us seriously all my favorite
youtubers have always had loot crate at
one point I'm like why isn't lucre
Devery contacted us because this was the
time this needed to be the boost
I mean sure we've done other unboxing
videos but this is the one I've always
wanted to be a part of I'm so happy I
got this knife from Colorado
in just a week after we got noticed by
Grace Randolph I know we had to really
work hard to the whole year all right
let's do this one at a time all right
I'm not even gonna look at your lap not
that I ever do okay let's just reach in
here whoo I feel this shirt numb hearts
light i'm atlanta l-- lanyard lanyard
landal is the name of the guy and your
Kingdom Hearts lanyard hell yeah look at
this guy's who looks like a badge
to a kingdom so when we go to comic-con
yeah you can show off your fandom will
be like hey guys did you watch that
video that explains Kingdom Hearts in 30
minutes it's really easy to follow to
watch our reaction for that thanks
Michael B key sword
alright John alright okay what's it I
hear so I'm sure you'll be inside of the
box
shaky graves that's not the box haha
that's my Dewey Cox diner diner whoa oh
that's some assassins cream in this
right good that bad boy might be upside
down oh yeah yeah it could be if you
want loot crate is so happy to be
partnering with us I'm very annoyed with
my fandom if you want to make it like an
off-brand V for Vendetta you go right
ahead let's see right here what do we
got inside oh oh oh
play or color bling tonight Assassin's
Creed playing cards my girlfriend is a
huge Assassin's Creed fan and she loves
poke and she's a gambling do you need to
talk I'm sorry I'm sorry John yup
they're their cards but they look like
really nice cards it look like the like
the fabric you oh oh yeah they're all
Assassin's Creed it out look at that
look at that King they're all Assassin's
Creed it out hell yeah
this is gonna the best place to use
these as a magic show for nerds yeah
because you can a dazzle and reference
all its safety this is awesome yeah yeah
I only have a deck of we finally have a
deck of can you touch that I asked
because I want to respect your
enthusiasm over the loom erase all your
touching the cards whoa that's cool is
it like a pouch Ursa I think it's a
pouch or is it a mouse pigeon is it like
a mouse row Wow
I always save the shirt for last I think
it's a mousepad that's awesome oh you
didn't even read it
Skyrim oh yeah I rock hammer fell that
makes sense that it's a mousepad because
it's Skyrim ah yeah it's the world it's
the realm off so whatever they call them
we're just gonna keep that bad boy right
here oh yeah we got some stuff we got
some stuff got some stuff we got some
parts key key sword look out a sword I
learned what that was about in that 30
minute video which was a total blast to
watch you open stuff and beat the crud
out of people whoo-hoo there is a good
thing to give to a girl would be like
you get the key to my heart or my king
I'm hard like a Kingdom Hearts
yes dumbass sorry I'm a heartless that's
me if we get a badge from the gaming
division for their loot crate blade look
at that you guys can see it's in focus
yeah man totally clear oh what's this oh
it must be a post something new for the
background perhaps it's the key to
everything
oh oh
elder scrolls the dance cipher if you're
watching this video you're getting a
gift that's free for me so it's free for
you look at that such a cool poster and
I play elder scrolls once a day always
before making dinner that's why I'm
giving it to Dan that's how much this
gift means to me
yeah you know the truest loves are the
things you give away and if he gives it
back to you you know was meant to be for
you and I then I'm gonna truth shirt
momento de Oh best game of the year God
of War right you get your crate Oh son
oh man okay is in my size I would assume
extra small perfect that is my size
since I lost weight if those nipple
chills right there et extra small and
it's a great way to like do like a Hulk
muscle rip you know oh thanks dawg
Johnny a shave my chest crepe for me
it's a right training you get Luke Rey I
get Greg crepe
oh yeah oh yeah okay I have a God or you
are all you need is some kind of big
chain blade thing and a little kid you
know a kid sidekick there look after
like boys of the world guys thank you
Luke rate Luke gaming yes Luke gaming I
loot constantly so this is totally on
brand with my personal life appreciate
it very much guys if you want your own
loot Gaming loot crate box you guys go
right ahead hit that link in the
description box so for all these awesome
goodies yourself some cool you guys can
subscribe the reject nation click that
notification bell and check us out on
loot crate we post daily over there all
the memorabilia we make